- It's great to have you
- at "The Voice."
- Yeah.
- But, do you think you're gonna win?
- Do I think I'm gonna win "The Voice?"
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna win.
- [Kelly] You're pretty sure?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- You know I'm gonna win "The Voice."
- You have a really good team.
- Yeah, my team's fire.
- You have a good team.
- I don't know, I might
win it, I don't know.
- Your team is good.
- I don't know.
I feel like it's a different show.
I've done another competition.
- I know you have, too.
- Uh-huh.
- "Rhythm + Flow," right?
- Yeah. "Rhythm + Flow."
- Yeah. So, I've done something else too.
This one's different for me.
Is "The Voice," is it what you expected?
- It's a lot different than
I thought it was gonna be.
It's a lot of fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We have a lot of fun.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] You're funny.
- We have a lot of jokes, huh?
- You are. I have cried.
- And, had to have makeup
redone, kind of funny.
- Yeah.
- I think that's my
favorite part about it.
It's like a very easy environment.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like you and Blake
and Niall are all cool.
Everybody that works on the show is cool.
And, it's a lot more hands on
than I thought it was gonna be.
You know, like, I do, like,
production work and stuff.
- Yeah.
- For Peter Cottontail.
- Getting to work on the
arrangements of the songs,
and on, like, the vocal production part.
Can I say what's going on the show yet?
- I don't know if you can say.
- No, okay.
- No, but, I will.
- Well, she knows.
- Way better than I can.
- No, no, I don't know what you can say.
But I will say, that's been
my favorite part watching you.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Because I don't know if
I've ever really done it
with a full on producer before.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
You're a rapper, you're
a singer, and a producer.
And, it was interesting
to do the blinds with you.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Because, I was threatened.
(both laugh)
- 'Cause I was like, "Oh
wait, what? I can't do that."
Like, what he just did. Like, it was cool.
You were like producing,
like, during the blinds.
That was part of your pitch.
- [Chance] Yeah.
- Which I didn't like.
(audience laughs)
- [Chance] You didn't like?
- No, I liked it for you.
I didn't like it for me. (laughs)
- You got everybody that I,
there was a bunch of times
where we turned, right.
- Okay.
- And you were like,
- They'd be like.
- There were a bunch of times
- [Kelly] you got it.
- [Chance] There were maybe two times.
- No.
- But most of the people.
- [Chance] Kelly, what?
- Lies. Lies and deception.
(audience laughs)
- They would give a whole
speech about how they love me,
and "Oh, come on, and book."
And, were like, "But Kelly Clarkson."
(Kelly laughs)
And, then they'd go to you.
- I feel like that happened with Niall.
- I think it's a-
- Niall did get a-
- They picked Niall.
- Niall got a few steals.
- [Kelly] I know I can't, yeah,
I can't compete with that.